je ne sais pas quels amis youtuber a
oublié ses lunettes de mon bureau mais
en tout cas elles sont écoulés voilà
plutôt que d'envoyer vingt mille sms
c'est plus simple si tu vois la vidéo
via la récupérer elle sont variables
elles sont cassés maintenant les a mais
vous le savez sur cette chaîne youtube
j'adore faire ce qui me plaît alors des
fois on fait des petits sketchs des fois
on fait des vidéos un pro des fois c'est
d'humour des fois on regarde des vidéos
et aujourd'hui je vais parler d'un sujet
qui me passionne mon gars on a tous un
petit truc qui nous passionne dans la
vie j'espère si c'est pas le cas c'est
juste que vous l'avez pas encore trouvé
mais la portion des trucs qui m'ont
passionné tôt ou tard moi c'est les bras
et red dead redemption de aussi un peu
en ce moment mais sinon ça aujourd'hui
j'ai trop envie d'en parler il ya plein
de choses à apprendre autour de ce sujet
de la loire c'est fascinant et en plus
ça jamais été autant d'actualité parce
que comme on est en train de nuit qui
est littéralement la planète enfin on
est en train on l'a déjà quasiment
entièrement [ __ ] il va falloir qu'on
aille vers une autre planète on est
comme ça nous on x qu'on appuie on va
trouver un truc similaire et on va les
[ __ ] à ce tour c'est comme ça je vais
essentiellement vous parlez de mars
parce que c'est a priori la prochaine
destination de l'humanité dans l'univers
je vous racontais un peu où on en est un
petit peu d'ordre dans l'astronomie
pourquoi on veut aller sur mars et face
à quels problèmes faisons nous fasse un
problème dans cette phrase est présent
trouver là pour aller sur cette fameuse
planète rouge
connaissez-vous les ss l'international
space station dont la construction a
commencé à la fin des années 60 c'était
une idée des soviétiques les américains
ont marché sur la lune c'était
incroyable et les soviétiques que se
sont dit ok c'est bien marché sur le
satellite de la terre il faut savoir
qu'à lui n'y a rien à y faire n'y a pas
d'atmosphère c'est pour ça d'ailleurs on
voit qu'elle a des trous elles se
mangent des tas de météorites et
d'objets qui passe dans l'univers et
elle n'abrite rien qui puisse nous aider
ni oxygène ni au bref rien n'est
propices à la vie là-bas donc on a rien
à [ __ ] en tout cas de manière durable
les ssd soviétiques l'ont donc conçu
parce qu'ils voulaient vivre et
travailler dans l'espace de manière
durable et ils ont réussi parce qu'elle
est continuellement occupé depuis 1971
c'est à dire qu'au moment où on parle il
ya des gens qui sont là haut dans les ss
et qui voient ce spectacle
[Musique]
alors je me suis aperçu en parle un peu
de cette passion que j'ai autour de moi
que les gens ne savent pas pourquoi l
iss existent et ils ne savent encore
moins ce que les astronautes fond dans
cette fameuse station et c'est vrai que
quand tu t'intéresses pas le sujet va
t'en sais rien et tu du pacs à une
quelconque utilité en fait qu'on fait là
haut est pourtant mec est pourtant en
gros grâce à leur expérience on apprend
énormément de choses pour pouvoir mener
à bien des voyages spatiaux long
pourquoi des voyages spatiaux long parce
que mars c'est loin sa mère en moyenne
mars et à 70 millions de km de la terre
te dire que pour y aller faut qu'on
fasse 70 [ __ ] de millions de
kilomètres et je vous dis ça parce que
c'est un problème qui est au coeur des
interrogations de la nasa de lézat et de
l' agence russe la durée du trajet pour
aller sur mars
et pour revenir avec les systèmes de
propulsion actuelle on mettrait six mois
à atteindre
marx mais comme les deux planètes
bougent leur tour lui serait beaucoup
plus long puisqu'il prendrait un an et
trois mois et la mission elle sur marc
duret au final un mois c'est à dire
qu'il ya presque deux ans de voyage pour
ne rester qu'un mois sur place c'est dur
elle pose problème déjà pour une
contrainte physique on a évolué sur
terre depuis toutes ces années on est
soumis à la gravité et le corps humain
n'est pas fait pour survivre dans un
milieu où il n'ya pas de gravité
souvenez-vous vu jeff à 20,0 j'ai en
plus je peux vous dire un peu ce que ça
fait au corps mais moi c'était des
séries de 20 secondes
eux ils seraient six mois donc c'est pas
la même l'oreille interne est
complètement perdue donc pendant
quelques jours on a la nausée puis après
le corps s'habitue et surtout la
conséquence la plus importante des taux
à zéro g pendant un long moment c'est la
perte de masse musculaire et masse
osseuse et ça ça fait chier parce que
quand tu as fait six mois en zéro g et
tu reviens à linge et sur terre bâton
corps mongai se prend un uppercut dans
la gueule il comprend plus ce qui lui
arrive pour faciliter le retour des
astronautes
ils font donc du sport tous les jours
pendant deux heures pour maintenir une
certaine masse musculaire et osseuse
pour que quand ils reviennent sur terre
puisse encaisser le choc
et chose encore plus grave que la perte
de masse musculaire et osseuse c'est le
vieillissement des parois artérielles
parce que comme toys et roger tous les
fluides de ton corps remontés en gros le
sang ne va plus dans tes jambes on
considère que quand tu passes six mois
dans l'espace des parois artérielles ont
vieilli environ autant que quelqu'un qui
a passé de 30 ans sur terre c'est abusé
alors rassurez vous pour nos chers
d'astronautes quand ils reviennent sur
terre les parois se régénère et au final
y'a aucune conséquence à long terme de
leur voyage dans l'espace mais si tu
fais six mois en zéro g + 1 - 0,36 g +
15 mois en zéro g on ne sait pas si
c'est rattrapable vieillissement des
parois artérielles et on sait pas même
si tu vas pas crever en fait dans
l'histoire tellement une voix et
endommagé ses parois on est donc face à
un premier problème alors il ya des
solutions qui sont envisagées en gros
l'idée ce serait de recréer au sein du
vaisseau la gravité qu'on a sur terre
comment faire dans un vaisseau spatial
pour recréer la gravité terrestre la
force entre excusez moi je chante c'est
que je suis très heureux de parler de ça
donc j'ai besoin de chanter on pourrait
mettre une petite centrifugeuses dans le
vaisseau qui permettrait de soumettre le
corps du coup de l'astronaute à une
gravité plus ou moins proche de celle de
la terre et donc que son corps ne se
déshabitue pas complètement du milieu
terrestre
bon bah du coup on est bon on peut aller
sur mars ah si seulement il faut savoir
que sur terre on a la chance d'avoir un
atmosphère est donc un champ magnétique
qui entoure la terre et qui nous protège
d'énormément de choses ça nous protège
des météorites des comètes des éruptions
solaires franchement on est bien sur
terre mais lors d'un voyage spatial
surtout quand ils durent six mois ou
quinze mois pour le retour on a plus
d'atmosphère dans le vaisseau on est
fragile on est soumis à tout ce qui
passe à travers l'espace y compris les
tempêtes solaires et rayons cosmiques et
on a beaucoup là où tout ça c'est des
radiations les radiations de vous
connaissez ça endommage son adn et ça
entraîne des tumeurs des cancers et
cetera bresse avait duré
considérablement l'espérance de vie nos
astronautes
alors pour que le voyage se passe bien
avec nos astronautes arrive en pleine
santé faut se protéger de sa est
actuellement ce qu'on connaît pour se
protéger des radiations c'est l'eau donc
il faudrait mettre une couche de 2 à 3
mètres d'épaisseur tout autour du
vaisseau rempli d'eau ce qui est
impossible ça pèserait je sais pas
combien de kilos et on pouvait pas faire
décoller la fusée alors les
scientifiques essaient de recréer un
champ magnétique exactement comme celui
qui nous protège ici sur terre sauf que
là ce serait pour protéger le vaisseau
mais comment on fait pour produire ce
champ magnétique là j'en sais rien je ne
suis pas scientifique mais il travaille
dessus et apparemment ils ont des pistes
donc on pourrait réussir à faire ça ce
qui serait déjà une très grande avancée
un autre problème bien sûr c'est comment
les astronautes vont ils pouvoir se
nourrir boire respirer et évacuer leurs
déchets la station spatiale
internationale se situe à 400 kilomètres
au dessus de nous ce qui veut dire qu'on
peut leur envoyer des provisions assez
facilement c'est pas si loin c'est même
très proche en fait à l'échelle du
système solaire je sais plus tous les
combien de temps mais je sais qu'on
envoie un cargo aux astronautes qui sont
dans les ss dans lequel il ya de la
nourriture des vêtements en bref des
biens et des vivres pour qu'ils puissent
survivre là où enfin une fois qu'ils ont
vidés ils le remplissent avec leurs
déchets et quand ce truc-là repart de la
station bas ils crament dans
l'atmosphère et ça a permis aux
astronautes de garder une station clean
il faut quelques heures pour atteindre
iss née pour atteindre mars on l'a dit
il faut plusieurs mois des astronautes
vont donc devoir survivre grâce à un
écosystème c'est à dire qu'ils vont
devoir consommer tout ce qu'il crée donc
pour leur nourriture on va créer des tas
de plantes ce qui va permettre en plus
de créer de l'air de l'oxygène pour
qu'il puisse respirer les déchets qu'ils
produisent bah faut qu'ils soient
recyclables pour qu'il puisse fabriquer
autre chose derrière avec pour les
outils par exemple plutôt que d'emmener
des caisses et des caisses d'outils
il ya une idée s'était donné une
imprimante 3d qui leur permettrait
d'imprimer les outils dont ils ont
besoin et de le faire fondre derrière
pour en fabriquer un autre quand ils ont
besoin d'un autre outil une autre
contrainte aussi à laquelle on pense pas
forcément c'est la contrainte
psychologique on va mettre des gens dans
un espace confiné pendant des mois et
ces gens là vont devoir travailler en
équipe pendant toute la durée du voyage
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu une embrouille
tu vas pas faire la gueule dans un coin
et ne rien faire pendant un mois ça
marche pas à sauf que l'humain n'est pas
fait pour être collée à d'autres humains
dans un espace aussi petits pendant une
longue période déjà pendant une courte
période eu pète un câble pendant
plusieurs mois je t'en parle même pas il
va donc falloir choisir minutieusement
qui on envoie sur mars parce qu'il n'est
pas question qu'un conflit éclate au
sein du groupe surtout vu le prix que ça
coûte de les envoyer sur mars et vu les
enjeux si tout ça s'est gâché par une
embrouille parce qu'un mec a pas fait la
vaisselle c'est stupide
en parlant de psychologie une autre
contrainte en fait c'est du tout
simplement le fait de se retrouver aussi
loin de la terre c'est à dire que tu es
tellement loin de la terre que tu ne la
voient même plus en fait les seuls les
humains avoir perdu de vue la terre
c'est ce d'apollo 11 quand ils ont dû
faire le tour de la lune pour revenir
sur terre mais c'était vraiment sur une
très courte durée on ne sait pas ce que
ça peut provoquer chez un humain de ne
même plus voir la terre on a du mal à
s'imaginer mais je pense que ça doit
être terrible tu dois vraiment te dire
ok chez moi c'est vraiment très très
loin c'est terrible mais n'oubliez pas
il faut qu'il fasse pousser des plants
pour pouvoir vivre donc ça leur
rappellera un peu la terre et ça leur
fera je pense beaucoup beaucoup de bien
je pense que sans ça vraiment eu pète un
câble selon thomas pesquet vu ce que
c'est d'aller sur mars c'est vraiment le
plus gros truc que l'humanité fait de
son histoire c'est tellement motivant
pour l'équipage de dates le premier à
faire ça à aller sur mars et c'est
tellement un grand pas pour l'histoire
d'humanité que au final perdre la terre
de vue c'est pas tant un problème que ça
moi je ne veux pas la perdre de vue je
vous le dis et enfin un autre gros gros
gros problème c'est l'atterrissage sur
mars
l'atmosphère de mars est très très très
fine donc pour atterrir quand on
parachute ça te ferait beaucoup moins
que quantum un parachute sur terre sauf
que là tu as 30 tonnes qui arrive à la
vitesse de 5 ou 6 km par seconde pour
les arrêter mon gars faut y aller
le soyouz par exemple le véhicule qui
amène et ramène les astronautes de la
station spatiale internationale
à l'avant il ya un gros bouclier
thermique est en fait cram à la place du
vaisseau lorsqu'ils rentrent dans
l'atmosphère sur mars est pareil alors
elle est plus fine atmosphère mais elle
est quand même là et on arrive tellement
vite que ça brûle très fort d'après les
estimations faudrait un bouclier
thermique qui fasse 25 mètres de
diamètre
sauf que pareil c'est beaucoup trop gros
et lourd pour être amené dans l'espace
et le bouclier même si freinerait
beaucoup le vaisseau il suffirait pas
pour dire ensuite déployé un parachute
sauf que comme l'érythrée fin faudrait
que le parachute face la taille d'un
stade de foot et c'est pas tout même
après ça on est encore à 2000 km heure
donc il faut des fusées qui pousse dans
l'autre sens pour freiner le vaisseau
quoi
c'est compliqué alors ce qui est
encourageant c'est qu'on a déjà réussi à
envoyer des sondes sur marche y en a
plusieurs à leur ont parlé prévoit
encore d'envoyer est globalement il ya
que un atterrissage sur trois qui échoue
qui est plutôt encourageant en fait
alors pourquoi on veut aller vers mars
et pas une autre planète parce que mars
par le passé a eu des similitudes avec
la terre comme par exemple ne serait-ce
que la présence d'eau nécessaire à toute
forme de vie on peut trouver sur mars
des traces de lacq et c'est très
encourageant mars a aussi une atmosphère
une fine atmosphère bon pas du tout
comme celle de la terre mais quand même
ça reste un point commun entre les deux
planètes et ya pas beaucoup de planètes
coin atmosphère et des tas d'autres
trucs que je sais pas mais demandé aux
scientifiques ils vous diront non mais
voilà en gros c'est la planète sur
laquelle on met un peu nos espoirs parce
que voilà elle présente des trucs commun
avec la terre alors même si à rien de
vivant sur mars y avait rien de vivant
aussi a très longtemps sur terre et
pourtant la vie est apparue alors
peut-être que mars de nous permettre de
comprendre comment la vie est apparue
sur terre comment on est passé de la
matière inerte à quelque chose de vivant
des amis à trop de problème là dans
cette vidéo c'est ça fait chier mais
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est de
savoir pourquoi on n'est pas encore sûr
mars pourquoi n'y a pas encore une
colonie d'humains là bas bref on a
beaucoup de bâtons dans les roues mais à
priori le premier humain par tirer en
direction de mars dans les années verge
en 2025 a priori d'après les gens les
plus ambitieux comme voyez il ya encore
beaucoup de problèmes à résoudre et 2025
c'est demain j'ai énuméré les plus gros
problèmes et y en a beaucoup d'autres je
suis pas scientifique de toute manière
donc à plein de trucs que j'ai dû
oublier ou quartz y en a qui veulent
apporter des précisions de les
commentaires va éviter pas j'espère que
vous avez passé un bon moment même si ça
vous fait pas plus ce qui fait que ça à
l'espace bas je dois vous aurez appris
des trucs et que vous trouvez ça un peu
plus intéressant désormais voilà en tout
cas j'en aurais parlé donc je suis très
content si vous voulez faire partie des
premiers aller sur mars
n'hésitez pas à y revient dans la
description pour postuler c'est
entièrement faux
j'aimerais bien mais ces fonds on peut
pas en voyons plutôt de la force à
thomas pesquet qui ça se trouve fera
partie des premiers à aller sur mars
[ __ ] je vous fais des bisous comme
d'habitude je vous dis à très dans une
prochaine vidéo et puis voilà portez
vous bien allez hop je vais moins loin
que sur mars parce que je vais chez moi
voilà cinq kilomètres ça va
[Musique]
on